hey job we know you're a super
competitive guy
but is it possible for you after this to
feel
both the hurt of losing and also feel a
lot of hope for the future
based on the way you were able to play
and what your team was able to prove
uh you know i can uh say i'm you know
i'm disappointed um
definitely you know we're losing i mean
nobody likes to lose
um but i mean the positive side um i
mean we we know we
we we're right there um just was some
games away
um so we know we just you know go back
to work
um and just get ready for next season
terry davis
hey john i know when you came into this
game you had you took the challenge on
because a lot of people don't give you
credit for your defense
and you did a great job you know for the
most part containing cj
mccullum for the year so how do how do
you take your defense on and try to roll
that even
even better for next year um
it's just you know me um getting in
better shape
um later in the game today you know i
was fatigued
i think i played the whole second half
so it's just you know finding breaks
uh finding ways to take breaks on the
offensive end and you know
still on the defensive end and you know
tonight um
cj you know i think it was two isos in a
row i think a three and a pull-up
um you know i was guarding him um you
know i
i watch him a lot i mean that's what he
what he do um
i'm just trying to you know make the
shot as tough as possible for him
to try to get a stop gary washburn
um seems like dame and cj
guys making the veterans make it easier
on themselves by getting to the line and
getting easy points
it seems like you weren't getting some
calls you weren't getting that contact
how do you kind of change that is it
just experience and it's how frustrating
is it being on the stretch
when you're you're getting knocked on
the floor
it's just it's it's you know it's it's
not resulting
and getting too long um i think that
question was a low-key a trap
for me trying to get fined but um
i mean growing up my pops always told me
you know never called fouls um i always
go to finish through contact so
that's really about it um i can't
control you know what happens in the
game but
um i mean that's you know just me just
go finish the play instead of you know
worrying about
if the call is made or not
evan barnes
john this season you guys have almost
maybe
not exceeded your expectations but
exceeded a lot of people's expectations
so
going now into the off season do you
feel more pride at what you accomplished
or as you said
more hunger just to get better knowing
you guys were this close to getting to
the playoffs
um man i just said you know i'm proud of
everybody our whole style our players um
i mean we played through a lot of
adversity we faced you know
injuries early in the season uh starting
with me and then brandon
and jaron and you know coming here um
you know we still face you know some
injuries from some key guys um on the
team but
i mean we never gave up you know i'm
proud of our fight
um if anybody knows me they know every
time i you know i step on the floor
i'm gonna give it my all and for the
past
i say four games um since the raptors
game i was out there playing with a
fractured thumb so
um i mean i'm gonna give it my all
regardless
you know i fight many battles in life
but
um i you know i never give up
i mean we just gotta you know take away
the good from this season i'll get back
to work in the off-season
and you know prepare for next season
got time for one more question taylor
rooks hey john
uh when you look back on your rookie
season what will stick out the most
oh man um
see how close i was to the playoffs um
i mean obviously now you know i feel
like i kind of know what it takes
you know to make it wheel some games
away um
i learned a lot through the amount of
games i played this whole season um
you know it's i say people try to put a
lot of pressure on me but
i'm a rookie i just turned 21 a couple
days ago so
at this point i'm still learning um but
i have the right you know guys around me
from
family to my staff to my teammates um
always you know encouraging me and you
know giving me good tips
um to you know make it through push
through so
um i mean i felt like i got better as
you know the season went on um obviously
not the outcome we wanted but
um we we have to be proud of you know
what we accomplished this season
coming in being projected to be 27th in
the league
and was right there in the play in
yangon style
all right john thanks for joining us